[Applauso]
può 18 minuti
io continuo a pensare che il tempo sia
il vero lusso di questo momento storico
insomma non si può prelevare un quarto
d'ora da una banca del tempo e riaverlo
quindi penso sempre che vada usato nel
migliore dei modi
cercherò di farlo anche in questa
occasione taker così abbiamo intitolato
questo incontro di ted per brescia
prendersi cura del proprio tempo quindi
e attraverso le cose che si fanno la
calligrafia è stata quella che la cosa
che mi ha cambiato la vita che io ho
incontrato è quella che mi ha insegnato
ad apprezzare il tempo e altre cose di
cui adesso vi parlerò attraverso queste
immagini
io ho incontrato la scrittura
quando studiavo graphic design però nel
contempo stava avvenendo qualcosa nel
milanese dintorni diciamo in italia sei
le cose arrivano sempre un po dopo
quindi nei primi anni 90 ho scoperto il
writing
ed è una storia d'amore per le lettere
quella di cui vi parlo il writing è una
disciplina che molti riconoscono con la
parola graffiti
quello che mi ha insegnato in età molto
giovane è stata trasferire delle
proporzioni molto piccole e quindi avere
una progettualità quella cosa che tu fai
seduto a una scrivania in completa
solitudine comunque una cosa molto
intima in qualcosa che diventa poi
enorme quindi trasferire queste
proporzioni allenare il proprio occhio
al trasferire un gesto da un media
all'altro e mi ha insegnato proprio a
prendere proporzioni con il mio corpo
come faccio a sapere se sto scrivendo
dritto da qui a cui prendo la misura
della mia testa del mio braccio la
grandezza di una lettera e la posso
riprodurre anche senza avere quella
visione dall'alto che è quella che ci fa
vedere le cose nel suo insieme
c'era un ed a palermo di massimo pitis
che è un amico grafico che parlava di
una mosca su un tappeto
ecco la mosca seduta ferma su un
particolare vede solo quel particolare
quando inizia a volare vederli insieme e
capisce che è parte di una cosa più
grande di se questa trova una bella
metafora e quando sei vicino a un muro
così non riesce a capire che cosa sta
accadendo lì però sai che c'è un insieme
e devi tenere sempre presente questa
cosa io sono sempre stato interessato
alla scrittura pura quindi questi sono
strumenti una bomboletta spray per
creare delle texture la texture è creata
da bianco e nero e questo uno dei primi
concetti che mi interessano molto bianco
e nero è l'eterno dualismo una cosa non
succede se non c'è il suo opposto un
elemento non esiste senza il suo
contrario
quindi questa
lettura è un colore grigio formato da
elementi bianchi elementi neri e il
bello è quando sono in armonia per
capire questo concetto deve iniziare a
pensare che non scrivi in nero su bianco
ma scrive in nero e bianco e addirittura
il bianco quindi il vuoto è più
importante dell'elemento stesso in
questo caso una lettera nera su un
foglio perché saper vedere in negativo e
anche secondo me la prima metafora che
ho imparato del saper vedere le cose da
un punto di vista diverso quindi non
guardo più quello che sto scrivendo ma
guardo il bianco che lascio ed è un
concetto che sembra semplice ma semplice
vuol dire facile quindi per capirlo ci è
voluto un po di tempo
questo strumento che avevo spesso in
tasca poteva per esempio fare questo
tipo di scrittura ma anche questo tipo
di scrittura
quindi non è una questione di la
calligrafia intesa come un signore
ricurvo con una candelina col pennino
con la penna d'oca ma questa
rappresentazione che ci danno spesso in
meglio anche il film o comunque la
nostra memoria storica ma è un gesto ed
è un gesto di 600 anni fa che può essere
fatto con uno strumento moderno questo è
un pennarello largo che si usa per fare
graffiti ma questa scrittura è del 1500
quindi non è una questione di quanto sia
attuale e di quanto si attualizza
attraverso i suoi strumenti potrei dire
che per esempio molti non sono d'accordo
con questo ma perché ci sono i puristi
come in tutti gli ambienti sono gli
hater i puristi i maniaci e quelli che
la prendono con serenità
io sto cercando di prendere la più con
serenità e quindi mi piace provare nuovi
strumenti per scrivere c'è anche questo
strumento semi matto è quando c'è queste
cose qui addosso perché se nel tuo mondo
veramente nel tuo mondo vr la realtà
virtuale
sei in un mondo favoloso da cui tra
l'altro è difficile uscire perché tutto
perfetto ti credi tu il tuo sfondo 6
nell'ambiente tu vuoi tu e stai creando
la scrittura non mi dimensionalmente ma
tutto intorno a te viaggi in mezzo le
lettere un gesto non è soltanto in
questo senso ma in questo in questo e
quindi capisci che i gesti che stai
facendo per creare una lettera possono
avere anche mille anni è lo strumento
che cambia ed è quello che fa vivere la
scrittura in questo caso anche al giorno
d'oggi un'altra fase importante del
della mia esperienza con la scrittura è
stato l'insegnamento della calligrafia è
fondamentale
a un certo punto tramandare questa cosa
e tramandarla non vuol dire soltanto
utilizzare i social network i video ma
vedere persone realmente viaggiare
incontrare persone che hanno lo stesso
interesse per la tua cosa che sembra
così se totale così di nicchia ma se
cercate calligrafia su un social network
vi renderete conto che non è più così o
almeno è una cosa ciclica
adesso siamo stati in una ubriacatura
digitale incredibile e c'è un interesse
è ritrovato per le cose manuali perché
sono conquiste e la scrittura è una
conquista dell'essere umano
non possiamo buttarla via con una
cinquantina d'anni di tecnologia
eppure ce la stiamo facendo piano piano
io sono un guerriero lotto perché questo
non accada non insegno i bambini e
insegno a quelli un po più grandi
insegno calligrafia non scrittura quindi
bella scrittura la scrittura intesa come
un'immagine i corsi che faccio sono di
varia natura ma soprattutto sono in
tanti posti per cui questo è l'utenza
che ho avuto a chicago
l'america un grosso interesse ma è una
generazione prima in italia sono molto
più giovani sono designer sono statua
tori sono brighter come come lo ero io
in giappone sono così e la differenza
non è soltanto nell'età o nel target
quest'anno tutte donne quasi tranne
quello lì ma è che quando gli dici a un
italiano un brasiliano fa in una riga
così no la disciplina
lui fa così quando glielo dice un
giapponese fa la riga 15 ora a metterci
del tuo prova qualcos'altro no fino a
quando non faccio la riga come quella
che hai fatto tu io non smetto
e capisci che è sta insegnando alla
stessa cosa ma loro ti stanno insegnando
un modo diverso per assorbirla
completamente diverso e questa è
un'esperienza io dico sempre ho imparato
ad insegnare
ci ho messo una decina d'anni adesso di
stato proprio piacendo non solo per il
fatto che si viaggia e che si scoprono
dei posti in cui magari non saresti mai
stato ma perché si crea valore
ci sono persone a cui insegnato che anni
dopo mi scrivono sto lavorando con
questa cosa
ho due figlie mantengo la mia famiglia
quindi
è quel concetto del hai fame e non ti do
un pesce ti insegno pescara ed è molto
bello riconoscersi nel proprio lavoro
vuol dire essere anche riconoscibili
credo che una delle mete più difficili
per un designer io faccio calligrafia
applicata al design alla grafica è molto
difficile essere riconoscibili e
soprattutto quando non si ha un solo
stile è bello e forse funziona quando
qualcuno ti dice quel lavoro è tuo
da cosa l'ha riconosciuto sono tutti
diversi ma c'è qualcosa che non
comprendo che evidentemente metto in
ogni lavoro che poi diventa la tua cifra
stilistica questo è stato un lavoro
commerciale e io da piccolo quello che
che apprezzavo della calligrafia che non
sapevo ancora esistesse era l'esistenza
delle lettere sul packaging sulle
confezioni non vedevo la confezione di
cereali di caramelle diciamo a chi ha
disegnato questa scritta io non lo
sapevo però mi dava un emozione vedere
queste caselle copiavo e cercavo di
rifarle e credo che una volta che fai un
lavoro di questo tipo non è un semplice
lavoro di design è qualcosa che rimane
poi magari nella memoria collettiva
mi piace pensare che qualcuno maneggi
questa bottiglia che la vedo da qualche
altra parte del mondo senza avermi
conosciuto e che in qualche modo un
segno del mio passaggio fatto di
dettagli
sicuramente non avete idea di quanto
difficile sia farsi approvare una cosa
del genere perché magari la ypsilon non
è abbastanza svedese e la ti sembra un
segno religioso non vi dico però alla
fine questa cosa che hai fatto
sopravvive a te stesso che sei una
persona finita
a volte siamo degli esseri anche
spregevoli però il nostro lavoro
può essere
staccato da quello che siamo noi come
persone e anche vero che il discorso è
migliorarsi per migliorare quello che si
fa e quindi vi posso assicurare che
attraverso lavori tipo questo questo è
un rapper wired italia un articolo su al
jazeera ed è fatto da un l'art director
a un art director con si può dire due
palle così perché ce ne sono pochi che
sa che tu stai creando un'immagine
quindi non ti dice deve essere leggibile
deve essere comprensibile tu fai quello
che devi poi sarà un immagine che parla
il calligramma è un'immagine fatta di
scritte e è così che va visto non come
una cosa leggibile si fugge dalla
leggibilità proprio per perché è bello
quando un immagine parla da sé e dopo
entriamo nel suo livello di leggibilità
queste sono un po di logotipi realizzati
ovviamente ognuno ha il suo stile ognuno
alla sua implicazione c'è quasi sempre
un ispirazione dietro questo viene da
una etichetta discografica francese
questo dal lettering del cinema
manifesti cinematografici anni 60 e 70
che sono una parte della nostra
tradizione grande molto diversa da
quella americana e questi cerca di
trovare il proprio stile il proprio
stile è una somma delle proprie
esperienze
io non credo di aver mai inventato nulla
semplicemente di aver messo assieme
l'esperienza col writing un viaggio in
giappone un viaggio a san francisco
vedere il poster art psichedelica degli
anni 60 70
tutto questo alla fine diventa il tuo
lavoro e del fatto di piccoli dettagli
di cui prendersi cura così come la
tipografia è fatta di piccoli dettagli
ad un occhio non allenato i caratteri
sembrano tutti uguali cioè chi mi ha
detto non sapevo che i libri avessero un
carattere diverso
pensava forse lo stesso carattere
graziato per tutti e non è così un segno
messo assieme ad altri crea una
suggestione crea uno skyline
skyline o sono dei segni non lo so
dipende da cosa vogliamo vederci noi
e i dettagli sono quelli in cui la mosca
sta volando sopra per poi percepire
l'insieme ma la qualità di quelli
insieme non esiste senza i dettagli
ora io ho fatto diverse performance dal
vivo quelle proporzioni sono diverse non
non ho il controllo di tutto quello che
succede a volte cerco l'ispirazione
proprio per una frase come questa qui di
orwell wiev write
a volte mi trovo a lei questa qui l'ho
trovata proprio era un libro che usciva
da una libreria c'era scritto why e
wright giocavo lì è perfetta e l'ho
trovata poco prima della performance
cosa succede quando sei immerso nella
scrittura quando sei davanti a una
texture è che succede qualcosa che è
molto vicino alla meditazione
cosa succede quando stai per formando e
non sai non hai le righe non sai se
arriverà e alla fine del pannello con la
scrittura giusta non sai se farai degli
errori ai della gente dietro che ti
guarda a chi sotto ed è bellissimo
perché ti fa sentire vivo le persone
magari pensano che tu sappia cosa stai
facendo che ti sia tutto preparato e
invece non lo sai e quando viene bene se
il doppio soddisfatto ma è una cosa con
te stesso non sapranno mai gli altri
questa è una performance fatta con un
pianista cesare picco lui seguiva a me
con la musica
io seguivo la sua musica dietro avevamo
un pubblico io mi sono un certo punto
completamente dimenticato del pubblico
completamente ero assorto allora ho
capito che cos'è la meditazione ho
incominciato a capire che quale era il
mio rapporto anche a cercarlo il mio
rapporto con la spiritualità e qui è
questo il concetto che è scaturito miles
vuol dire essere qui e ora nel momento
in cui stiamo
facendo qualcosa completamente
[Musica]
concentrati su questo
quindi ci si perde nel bianco e nero
della scrittura e si è anche un
esercizio per un po maniacale forse però
è bellissimo come a un certo punto non
c'è più un punto focale ma tutta la
stessa importanza c'è un tipografo che
si chiama adrian frutiger tipografo
svizzero che ha riassunto questo
concetto del bianco e del nero con
un'immagine bellissima guardando
attraverso le foglie di un albero
la luce che entra dentro ecco la
tipografia questo la scali grafia anche
questo vedere la luce che entra
dagli elementi guardare l'opposto di
quello in cui si focalizza la maggior
parte delle persone quando guarda questo
è bianco e nero o no sono delle
sfumature del grigio quindi diventa
pittura e di lanciare tutto questo è
meditativo completamente meditativo ho
avuto l'esperienza bellissima con questo
signore che è un karateka dario marchini
nove volte campione del mondo e stando
nel dojo con lui ho capito che c'erano
delle grandissime analogie fra la sua
disciplina e la e la mia lui faceva una
o si faceva una n lo guardavo dicevo
queste cose sono molto simili
questo progetto si chiama vale
l'efficacia dell'art e l'arte efficace
quando una serie di gesti ripetuti
all'infinito con cura con dedizione
messi assieme creano un linguaggio che
poi diventa efficace così come la
scrittura quindi quello che che ho
capito è che la calligrafia per me è
soltanto una delle scuse con cui
guardare il mondo si chiama la via della
scala
la via della scrittura significa non
avere una meta ma godere del percorso
che si fa e questo molti di voi lo
troveranno metaforico per la propria
vita ma anche molto vicino a discipline
diverse dalla mia
e bellissimo non sapere dove arrivare e
godersi ogni passo che si fa
direi che la cura che ci si mette
l'attenzione per la propria disciplina è
quella che fa la differenza la
differenza diciamo che nel percorso
stesso e non risultato deve essere un
piacere prima di tutto e la gente
percepisce quando tu hai piacerebbe fare
qualcosa
quindi vi auguro sinceramente di
prendere il vostro piacere seriamente
grazie
[Applauso]